tı tken sahneye çıkarken Tiyatro
oyunlarında ya da bir koşudan önce 800
metreden önce hazırlanıp o silahın
atılma sesini duyduğunuz andaki heyecan
gibi şu anki çok tatlı yine twit yş
olmak ayrı bir
güzellik kendimi kısaca bir tanıtmak
istiyorum çünkü sizin çoğunuzu
tanımıyorum Üzgünüm ki benç gündüz T
2012 mezunlarından Koç Üniversitesi
Hukuk Fakültesi ve İşletme Fakültesi
çift öğrencisiyim asa uluslarası ilişk
girişim yani ile uğraşırken mi
bilmiyorum ya kulü ilgilenirken mi
kendimden beklediğim perform gösteremedi
için ulusları ilişk % gir or fakes geçi
kişiden bir
kıs böle tanım çok hoşlan değilim açıkçı
çünkü sadece bu kar değ ünitesi is
Birok
konuşm bölüme ayırdım ben farklı olmak
kendini tanımak
ve tanım yapmakla
başlıyor yağmurun konuşmasını Neyse ki
ben yapmayacağım yağ yaptı biraz gelir
Tamamdır küçük bir çalışmayla
başlayacağım Aslında bu Sabancı
Üniversitesi gittiğimizde yıcı
gizin biraz bundan bahsetmek istiyorum
Gülşe hoc masaya oturduk 78 kişiyiz
hepimizin önünde kağıt var Kalem var ve
bize şunu söyledi masada hiçbir şey yok
dedi ki Masanın ortasında duran
izmaritler dolu bir K tabağı hayal edin
ama Tepeli dolu işte sarı filtreler
olabilir Beyazlar olabilir arada inceler
olabilir ve sizden yarım saat içinde
Bununla ilgili bir öykü yazmanızı
istiyorum ve sonra birbirimizi
okuyacağız paylaşacağız çok güzel
Ben o an bir tek şunu hatırlıyorum Çok
net bir şekilde etraf dumanı Tab Bu
benim hayal Hera ve kar çok hiei or
sayıs kar Hi onlar eili birine daha
fazla değer verip birini anlatmak
diğerini değersizleştirmek olduğu için
hangisinden başlayacağımı
bilemiyorum
bütün örne yazdığımı Çünkü o güne dair
hatırladığım çok daha güzel bir öykü
vardı o da aybars'ın ve Aybars şu 14
kelimeyi benim Hatırladığım kadarıyla şu
14 kelimeyi yazmıştı ve bir anda
küllükte Duran tüm izmaritleri ağzına
doldurdu ve teker teker hepsini
yuttu şöyle bir durdum ve şeyi fark
ettim Aybar sanki beni Aman özgürleştir
ve Sınırlarımı zorlamıştı Çünkü orada
ben
Oğlunu askere gönderen bir anne
görüyordum ya da e Eşen ayrılmış bir
kadın görüyordum ya da yaratıcı yazı
başlaya çalışan Kafasında bir sürü
düşünce olan bir yazar görüyordum ama
sigaraları hepsini Teker teker alıp
ağzın yutacak insan açıkçası görmüyordum
ve nereden n gelmi bu yaratıcılığı onu
çok merak
ediyordum
sonk
ki yaparak beni daha da şaşırtmaya devam
etti Bu arada ayarsa bir tör öğrencisi
Şu anda vere mecmuayı çıkardılar vere
mecmuanın kapağına bazen her gün
yediğimiz karpuzu koyacak kadar bazen
Kurşun askeri çayın yanına yaraştırma
işetecek kadar sınırsızdır o farklıydı
benim gözümde çok farklıydı farklı
olmayı kendine Belki de bir amaç
edinmişti ama burada asıl sorulması
gereken soru şuydu
neden farklıydı yani niçin olan neden
değil de dolaylı olan neyden nelerden
farklıydı Çünkü bir şekilde kendini
tanımlamıştı orada bir Aybars vardı
ayars böyleydi aars böyle şeyler yazardı
Aybars özgürlüğünü altına İşletmeyi
uygun görürdü kendine Peki ya
buradakiler Neden görmüyordu şu
dünyadakiler neden bahsediyordu da Aybar
bunlardan
farklıydı O yüzden farklı olma söyle
başladım Aslında bu da hepinizin bildiği
o paydin dasa geliyor bir noktada Yani
evet hepimiz bir
yerde bir dünyaya aidiz Belki de ait
olmak istemediğimiz o toplumsal normlar
var bize Birileri bir şeyleri yapmamızı
söylüyor ya da Mahalle baskısıyla
yapıyoruz yapmak istemiyoruz oradan
kopmaya çalışıyoruz ve bundan farklı
olmaya çalışıyoruz orada da ikin Başlığa
geliyoruz önce farklı olmak için kendini
ve diğerlerini tanımlayabilmek için bir
çıkman gerekiyor Ben kimim kendini
keşfetmek isin yani Mesela bugün ben
farklı bir renk giyeceğim dediğimde Dün
ne giymiştim ki bugün ondan farklı
olacağım bunu düşünmeye başlıyor insan
ve ben ne renk severim ben kimim
sorusuyla devam ediyor burada da tekrar
farklılaştırmaya bağlayarak Aslında
mazdan girmek istiyorum ben çok
seviyorum mazun ihtiyaçları her şeye çok
güzel uyduğunu düşünüyorum ozanın Az
önce yaşamı için sürdürmekten bahset
yaşamak için sürdürmesi gereken
gereksinimler dediğinde kullandığı ya da
yağmurun kendini gerçekleştirmek
dediğinde kullandığı hep mazd
Aslında bilmeyenler için kısaca
özetlemek gerekirse mazo 1950'lerde
hümanistik bir yaklaşımla bu mana Sevgi
ya da kendini gerçekleştirme dediğimiz
kavramları tanımlamaya çalışmış bir
psikolog ve bahsettiği şey insanın
yaptığı her davranışın ihtiyaçların
Aslında davranışları başlatan ve devam
ettiren şeyler olduğu ve yaptığı her
davranışın bir güdüy le yapıldığı ve
ihtiyaçlar bu güdüler olduğu temelde en
hayvanların dahi yaptığı yemek yemek
ihtiyacı geliyor ikinc olarak güvenlik
ihtiyacı geliyor Daha sonra sevgi sonra
saygınlık ve sonra kendini
gerçekleştirme bu primitif ihtiyaçlar
yukarı Gittikçe daha da karmaşık ve
kendini gerçekleştirme dediğimiz kavram
o kadar soyut K tanımlaması oldukça zor
ama yapabilenler için çok mutluluk
verici Biz buran başlıyoruz bunu
Doğu da insan ve davranışı isimli
kitabında Ada örneğiyle çok güzel
veriyor yine somutlaştırmak adına bunu
söyleyeceğim ıssız bir odaya düşseniz
mesela ilk umursayan şey oturup Adadaki
günlerimi Dur bir kağıt kalem alıp
yazayım mı olurdu yoksa önce karnımı
nasıl duyuracağım derdine mi düşerdin
Karnınızı doyurduktan sonra da Peki ya
gece fırtına çıkarsa nerede kalacağım
derdine düşerdin ve kendinize kalacak
bir yer inşa ederdiniz sonra da acaba
odada Başkaları da var mı Dur bir etrafı
gezeyim derdiniz etf gezdiniz sonra bir
grubunuz olurdu belki ondan sonra o
grupta saygınlık edinmek isterdiniz
sonra da gruptan da aranıp kendi içimize
dönüp Bu sefer de neden buradayım ne
yapıyorum Ne yapsam kendim daha
gerçekleştirmiş olurum keman çalsam yazı
yazsam kendime döner miyim kendimi
Diğerlerine gösterir miyim ya da
Diğerlerine gösterme çabası değil asında
bu ama kendi Özümü nl gerçekleştiririm
sorusu geliyor işte şma dediğimiz şey 3
kademede oluyor Neden 3 kademe onu da
kardeşim örneğinden gitmek istiyorum
kardeşim ve ben birbirinden çok farklı
iki insanız Her konuda hayata bakış
açısı konusunda tavırlarınız konusunda
Hatta fiziksel günümüz bile farklı
Aslında o sarı saçlı mavi gözlü ben
esmerim çok emim yapamaz bayağı
Farklıyız diyebilirim Peki İkimiz de
annemin yaptığı Aynı yemeği yiyoruz o
zaman bir kademede aynı insanlarız
ikimiz de aynı ş altında yaşıyoruz
kademede de aynı şeylerle karşı
yaşıyoruz ama 3ün kademe işte Bizi
Birbirimizden farklı kılan o da onun
girdiği sosyal ortamla benim girdiğim
sosyal ortam Yani bu arkadaş aile ilişki
sevgili dediğimiz şeyler Onu Benden
farklılaştırılmamış bahsederek Beni
kabullenebilirim
insan anımsıyor Az önce bahsettiğim dasm
bir çıkış var Evet buradan farklılaş
dedik buradan doğrusal bir çıkış var ve
bir yöne doğru gidiyoruz kardeşimin
seçtiği başka bir hazır bir dünyaya
Entegre olma çabası herkes hazır bir
dünyaya Entegre olacak diye bir şey de
yok Benim seçtiğim kendimi yaratma
çabası kendi dünyamı yaratmam Yani benim
burada yapmaya çalıştığım Aslında
kendimi bir Koç Üniversitesi fut
fakültesi öğrencisi gibi tanımlarken
mesela yolda kazı çalışması yapan inşaat
işçilerine kolay gelsin demeden geçmeyen
biri olarak da tanımlayabilirim o da
benim dünyam derdim İşte bu benim
kendimi keşfetme çabam
içerisinde daha ik hafta önce döndüğüm
Kanada'da yeni bir keşif yolculuğu daha
başladı O da kendimi keşfederken Aslında
organik köklerim döndüğümü insanı ve
insanlığı tekrar keşfettiğim fark ettim
Bu nasıl oldu derseniz otobüse bindik
daha ilk yolculuğum uçaktan indim adaya
gitmem gereki fota giden otobüse bindim
ve otobüsten inen her yolcu şoföre
teşekkür etti güzel şaşırdım açıkçası
Nasıl yani Nasıl teşekkür eder Her yolcu
istisnasız Yani bir Türk olsa orada
derdi ki Neden teşekkür ediyorsun ki işi
bu zaten yapacak ama öyle değildi orada
insanlığa değer verdiğini gördüm
insanların ya da mesela feribota ya da
uçağa Grup numarasına göre aldıkları
önce yaşlılar sakatlar ya da çok küçük
yaşta çocuklar ya da bebekli ailelerde
ve bunu formaliteden yapmıyorlardı
gerçekten o insanların mesafeye yürürken
zamana ihtiyacı vardı ve onlara Lütfen
siz önden Buyurun kendinize bir yer
bulun rahat ettirin ve diğerlerini
arkadan alacağız diyorlardı ve ben de
tüm o doğanın doğayı zaten hiç
saymıyorum çok güzel iki konuşma daha
yapıldı bu konuyla ilgili o doğanın
içinde kendi keşfim şunu da fark ettim
insan aslında üniversite sınavı iyi bir
meslek daha sonra iyi bir aile derken bu
döngünün içinde döngü de değil Kendinden
uzaklaş tekrar geri dönmeyi organik
kökleriyle başarıyor yani özü insanlığı
tekrar keşfederek
ulaşıyor Peki ben kendi dünyamı Yarattım
kardeşim başkalarının dünyalarına egre
oldu da ben yalnız mı kaldım Hayır ben
kendi mı Yarattım başka bir Yarattım O
da hayır aslında Peki ben nasl Yal
kalmadım O da şöle oldu Şu
fark arkadaşım hala soruyor bir ilişkim
var mı Evet var 9 sınıfta sizin
yerinizde eyken dorukla tanıştım hala
birlikteyiz 7 yıl oldu peki Nasıl 7
yıldır birliktesiniz diye soruyorlar Ben
de onlara diyorum ki biz bir ilişki
yaşıyoruz Evet ama toplumun sana
baskıladığı yaşamanı emrettiği ya da
bunu böyle yap dediği bir ilişki
yaşamıyoruz Çünkü ben onun insanlığını
seviyorum Onun da benim gibi Yolda
geçerken yanında gördüğü çalışan işçiye
kolay gelsin demesini seviyorum onun
insanlığını seviyorum ve fark ediyorum
ki onun kendi kendine yarattığı dünyayla
benim kendi kendime yarattığım dünya bir
noktada örtüşüyor ve biz aynı dünyaları
paylaşıyoruz Burada da tekrar güzel bir
konuya geliyor Biz dasan koptuk o
doğrusal yolumuzu tamamladık kendi
dünyamızı yarattık Peki Nereden
anlayacağım Yani ben kendimi keşfettim
ben olmadığımı Anladım peki ya ben kendi
dünyamdaki Türkçeyi nasıl tanımladım
Çünkü o kadar önemli ki birçoğumuz
aslında kendi dünyamızda yaşıyoruz çok
güzel dünyalarımız var ama farkında
değiliz ben birçoğunu nasılsın diye
sorduğumda mutluyum cevabını almıyorum
aslında mutlusunuz ama bilmiyorsunuz
Çünkü doğru kelimeleri bir araya
getiremiyoruz kendini gerçekleştirmeden
gidelim mazo bunu çok güzel tanımlıyor
diyor ki bireyin kendi potansiyelinin
gizli gücünün farkına varması
Yani bazen eksik de kalıyor olabilir Bir
de şuna bakalım diyorum Tamam bu tanım
bir kenarda dursun Bir de bu kendini
gerçekleştirmiş insanların ortak
özellikleri var ne onlar kendilerini ve
diğer insanları oldukları gibi kabul
ediyorlar düşünce ve davranışlarda
spontane oluyorlar ve özerler yani
çevreden bağımsızlar H Yani benim
dediğime tekrar geldi çevreden
bağımsızlar Az önce var olan o siyah
Seferden uzaklaşmış bağımsızlar ona
dışarıdan bakıyorlar kendi dünyalarını
yaratmışlar Belki de Mutlular sadece
daha
tanımlayabilmek leştirme dedik oradan
Kendinin farkına varmaya geldik sonra
genel farkındalıktan farklı olmaya
geldik yani Türkçe Aslında o kadar güçlü
bir dil ki biraz düşünerek oradan buraya
kadar gelebiliyor musunuz Ben bunu
nerede keşfettim derseniz Türkçenin
gücüne hala ben çok inanırım ve kendime
en iyi ifade edebildiğim dilin hala
Türkçe olduğunu düşünürüm
bir aile hukuku dersindeyiz evlenmeyi
işliyoruz Tabii ki de nişanlanma evlenme
boşanma tane konu var zaten dönemin
yarısına evlenme evlenme evlenme evlenme
diye geçirmişiz Ben artık kelimeye
yabancılaşmış oturmuşum dste evlenme
Acaba ne demek Ne demeye çalışıyoruz
burada sonra Şunu fark ediyorum evlenme
dediğimiz Aslında iki ayrı evde yaşayan
insanın bir araya gelip y bir ev
edinmesi yani
evlenmesi çok değişik bir kelime değil
aslında Çok da mantıklı bir yerden
geliyor ya da bunu başka bir şekilde
tanımladığınız Dünya evine girme
diyorlar Bu da benim tanıma tekrar
dönüyor Doruk da benim yaptığım mesela
yapacağım daha ev değilim
evlendiğimizde o Dünya evine girmek
ikimizin dünyasını birleştirmek
aslında yani tekrar dediğim o ki doğru
tanım sizi doğru yerlere götürüyor ve
doğru hisleri hissettiriyor buna yine
hukuktan bir örnek vermek istiyorum Çok
sevdiğim bir konu hukuk felsefesi
üzerine bir konu hukuk fakültesinde
bizim fakültemiz en azından anlatılmayan
benim bir yaz okuluma öğrendiğim ve
farkına vardıktan sonra severek
paylaştığım başkalarının da Farkına
varmasını istediğim bir konu olduğu için
buraya getirdim onur ve şeref ayrımı biz
bu kavramları Onur haysiyet şeref
hepsini arelde kullanıyoruz Aslında
heisi birbirinden çok farklı kavramlar
ion bu konu üzerine çalıştı ve bunun
üzerine kitapları var ve şöyle diyor
Onun dediğiniz çekirdek bir kavramdır
İçinizde sakladığınız ancak sizin
görebildiğiniz ve sizin zarar
verebildiğin Oysa Şeref dediğinize
başkalarının da etki alanına açık sizin
başkalarının gözündeki değeriniz
bahseder yani ufak bir örnekle bir
birisi tecavüze uğradığında eğer o
durumdan rahatsız değilse kendisi
rahatsız olmadığı için tecavü tecavüz
fiilini gerçekleştiren kişi onurunu
zedeleme zk şerefini zedeliyor olabilir
aynı şekilde bu hukuk fakültesinde yine
ceza hukuku derslerinde çok verilen bir
örnektir taksimin ortasına bir bomba
yerleştirildiğini düşünün ve şüpheli bir
şahıs yakalamışsınız polis olarak onu
sorguya çekmeniz
gerekiyor işkence yapacaksınız çünkü
başka şekilde ondan bu bilgiyi almanız
mümkün değil Eğer işkence yapmazsanız
orada binlerce kişi zarar görebilir
ölebilir bombanın büyüklüğünü
bilmiyorsunuz Eğer işkence yaparsanız da
işkence yaptığınızda o insanın şerefini
Z de gideceksiniz ama şerefiniz
zedeleyecek sadece onurunu asla
zedelemeye yeleme ama yaptığınız bu
hareket onurunu zedeleme potansiyeli de
barındırıyor ve insan hakları evrensel
bildirgesinde kimsenin onurunun
zedelemeye söylüyor iyi bir hukukçu
burada bilir ki yaşam başkasının yaşam
Hakkı Onur dediğimiz kavramı Yanına bile
yaklaşamaz yani Onur dediğimiz o kadar
üstün bir kavram olarak korunur ki kimse
hiçbir şekilde ona zarar vermemelidir
zaten tartışmaya bile açık değildir Bu
iki kavramı karşılaşmayız bu durumda o
zaman iyi bir hukukçunun yapması gereken
şey şu korunan hukuksal Değer ne diye
soracak Ben burada 1in tane yaşam mı
koruyorum bir tane Onur mu koruyorum
Eğer soruyu doğru sorarsa yapması
gereken varması gereken sonuç o insana
işkence etmemektir Çünkü işkence hiçbir
şekilde kabul edilemez O yüzden 1000
tane yaşamın bir tane onurla
kılamayacağı bilir ve ona işkence etmez
Tartışmaya açık Kimileri yaşamın daha
değerli olduğunu savunabilir ama
Hukukçular her zaman buna böyle bakıyor
çünkü hukuksal tanımını doğru yapıp
hukuksal sonucunu doğru varıyor
psikolojik sosyolojik ya da başka
şekillerde başka tanımlarda farklı
sonuçlara varılabilir
tekrar geri dönelim toparlayalım ne
dedik farklı ol kendini keşfet ve doğru
tanım yap bunu nereye
bağladım bir arkadaşıma daha hafta önce
nasılsın diye sordum sıradan bir sözüydü
ve bana mutluyum dedi Ben de çok
şaşırdım çünkü bana daha önce kimseye
nasılsın diye sorduğumda mutluyum
cevabını almamıştım Peki neden mutlu
olduğunu biliyor musun dedim O da evet
biliyorum dedi çünkü benim şu an Mutlu
olmamı engelleyecek bir sebebim yok
Çünkü karnım doyuyor evim var okulumda
başarılıyım benim için bunlar yeterli
Onun için onlar yeterli olduğu için
mutluydu yani o birinci ve ikinci
kademeyi gerçekleştirdiği için mutluydu
Eğer sizin iin 5 kademede olmak yani 5
kademeye ulaşmak Yani kendini
gerçekleştirmek mutluluğa ulaştıracak o
zaman si 5 kademede mutlu olacaksınız
yalnızca burada önemli olan Bu başarı se
tüm kademeleri başarıyla nereye kadar
ulaşmak istediğini bilmeniz Eğer
biliyorsanız hiç problem yok o zaman
mutl olacaksınız demektir ama önemli
olan nede mutlu olacağınız tanımı doğru
ymak kendinizin bu piramit nerede
olduğunu i tanımlamak keşfetmek ve bir
şekilde o farklılığı yaratıp o
farklılıkla mutlu olup mutluyum
diyebilmeyi becermek Bence bunu en iyi
yapanlardan biri Apple Biliyorum çok
klasik bir örnek ama kendilerinin mosu
da böyle zaten Farklı düşünme başlıyor
Önce bir şu Dandan sıyrılıyor diyor ki
ıvm böyle ben böyle değilim Sonra bir
kendini keşfetme seine giriyor Peki ben
ne yapıyorum diyor Ben insanlara bir
hayat tarzı satıyorum ve sonra o sattığı
ürünü tanımlıyor ben bu hayat tarzını
satarken size böyle bir bilgisayar
yaparak satıyorum İşte bu Bilgisayarım
diyor son olarak sözümü bitirirken
Apple'ın O çok sevdiğim reklamıyla sizi
baş başa bırakmak istiyorum Teşekkür
ederim beni dinlediğiniz
için
the ones Who see
Things they're not f of Rules and they
have no respect for the Status
Quo you can quote them disagree with
them glorify or vilify them the only
Thing you can't do is ignore
them because they change Things they
Push the human Race forward and some May
see them As The Crazy ones
tekrar
teşekkürler
Merhaba
arkadaşlar öncelikle
Türkçe konuşması için teşekkür ediyoruz
sonra son bir kapanış konuşması yapm
Evet Size bir soru
soruyoruz Siz kimsiniz arkadaşlarınız
mısınız aileniz misiniz isminiz
misiniz yoksa ailenizin görüşe misiniz
hobiniz misiniz davranışlarınız miz Siz
Okul
Kon yoksa bular hiçb asıl cevap
sonun çünkü hiçbir şey yapmadığınız
zamanlar fakat hala var ol
düşünmediğiniz zamanlar ailenizin
arkadaşlarınızın bulunmadığı evinizde
olmadığınız zamanlar ve Böyle zamanlarda
Aslında Siz zamanı ve mekanı olmayan bir
benlik
ve sizin hayatınızın her türlü parçası
bu Benlik bir uzantısıdır Fakat bu Ben
siz tanıy ve de bu benlik zamanla
değişir Aslında bu etrafındaki olaylar
ve de zaman ve de en Fazlı
size ve biz bugün aslında şu soruyla
bitirmek istiyoruz
bu ne y
nası bgün burada Emeği geçen herkese
bütün konuşmacılar mıza bütün
organizasyon ekibimize yardımcı olan
bütün öğretmenlerimize ve
çalışanlarımıza Ve tabii ki geldiğiniz
için size çok teşekkür ediyoruz
düğümlendiği bir noktalar çok oldu bizim
organizasyon esnasında aksı giden her
şeye rağmen Bugünü gerçekleştirmemiz de
yardımcı olan
herkese teşekkür ederim
Teşekkür
by
h
Arş devam
edelim de
izleyelim
f
Benim telefonu da
alsana
kar
ben
gii
Ç
bilumu gördün mü